abone ol
e
Okul son gong column dersimizin konusu
selamlaşma vedalaşma kalıpları hal hatır
sorma yaşını sonra ve bunlarla ilgili
örnek diyaloglar Öyleyse selamlaşmayla
başlayalım ve koy sonra yani selamlaşma
kelimelerini neler Alo
hayho stash survce koş kot bunlarda çok
günlük konuşma dilinde kullandığımız
ifadelerdir Hello High cost eşcell rusko
scode Bir de günün makine göre olan
selamlaşma şekilleri vardır de Morgan
sabah demita öğlen demek Ama yatak gün
demek de Abant akşam kurye demek yani
İyi sabahlar iyi günler gibi utin Morgan
wantagh Hotel Avent Putin Morgan bot
nitocote nabid Bunlar hem resmi hem
günlük dizi sıklıkla kullanılan
ifadelerdir ve bu kelimeler ise Akşit
onların çöz ve şüphe ta
Isparta freebasing bu tırnak taht çöz
byspeed abisi petafrika zaman gotenna o
Fidan Sizin hem resmi hem günlük bir de
her türlü kullanılan bir ifadedir ama
diğer ifadeler daha çok günlük dilde
kullanılan ifadelerdir
Ha bir de Almanca mahsup ifade vardır O
da telefonda görüşmek üzere Yani altıda
hım
ve tekrar edelim Hello Hay Hah de hoş
kortsen woswogen Morgan Golden Takva
Tuna bınt süs ve spite biz pita alfrida
zina fide hı Not Allah
halo halo
kotakot uçak Sen buzkuş sis Çöz çöz 5
pita 6'da zina phenazine ve Spider
Spider Ha bir de Adımızı soralım ve
Adımızı söyleyelim Senin adın nedir Bir
Hurts to ya da Fiesta İnna mı i hystou
Western namı Adınız nedir Bir heresy
müziği ve istiyen ama ihal sizi ve
isteyene Ama
cevap verirken üç şekilde cevap
verebilirsiniz iş her sıvı Hem siz işin
hands My name is hommes hal hatır
sorarken de bir tane cümle kalıbımız var
nasılsın iki fıstığı
nasılsınız iki desteğinin iki testiye
iki desteğinin cevap verirken Eğer iyi
isek genellikle burada eski etmiyor
şeklindeki kalıp kullanılır Arkasından
da sıfat konur eski etmeye hud hud yani
İyiyim tankı eski etmeye gut Teşekkürler
iyi ve basket miyiz ekozer Çok demek
yani çok iyiyim eski etmeye Zehra kurt
eski etmeyen zoupa Eh Orta şekerli İdare
eder demek için merya eski dolu ya da
kısaca eski kötü olduğumuz zaman eski
etmeyen iş kot miniş olumsuzluk anlamı
nedir Yani iyi değilim eski etmeyen
işkurt eski etme yeşil hdplex kötü demek
eski etmiş eski etmez Eğer süreç çok
kötüyüm yaşımızı sorarken sayıları
ihtiyacımız var Bir tekrar edelim aynı
bayi daha it siyah söndü sxak
sweden aht noelle easton ev söz fightin'
12'ye kadar ezberlersin iz gerisi kolay
burada tek fabrikada etmemiz gereken 13
yerine 3 14.10 şekilde ters bu olması
gerektiği types in yani 3.10 fiyat senin
4.17 sonu s in deştiğin
ziftin aht innovance insentif
farkettiyseniz 16 ve 17 de bazı harfler
düştü Buna da dikkat edin sayılarla
ilgili ayrıntılı bir canım kartını
bıraktım tıklayıp video ulaşabilirsiniz
sorumlu soralım artık bir al pes Doğu
Kaç yaşındasın bir ertesi Doğu bir el
fiziği kaç yaşındasınız Eğer sizin iş
bin yağı aç işte insansı Şahı aç 20
yaşındayım ya da kısaca iş bir insan siz
diyaloğumuz tamamlamak için
tanıştığımıza memnun olabiliriz ne deriz
Tanıştığımıza memnun oldum ha 70 diş
Canon Sol Yanım koy etmiş düş Canon Sol
Yanım ya da sizi tanıdığıma memnun Biz
bunu daha mesafeli bir sohbet fethetmiş
zyxel'in sule yanım kaybetmiş ziken
türden Ben de memnun oldum miş al al
örnek çocuklarla dersimize tamamlayalım
hı hello hello bir heist o iş her
serleena advice to
iş her sıir kı bir ağaç ve stoğu 15
Bence antik yağı aç
15000 no insin
bitmiş değişkenin salam etmiş diş Canon
solanum mi shove düz Shoes
bu gösteriş
Bir Hayli zap2it istiyor
dankı utun fikri tesd ne ya eski etso
Ispart Martin
İsmail çöz
bütün tak bütün tak bir halsiz iyi iş
Halsiz clausi halsiz iyi iş bin Team
şimdiki test iğnenin
Ama sen kız Eğer good da fil yazın of
yazıyım
Ne dersiniz sona erdi konuyla ilgili
ayrıntılı PDF dosyası ekledim
indirebilirsiniz Yine oyun yükle
üzerinden alıştırma yapabilirsiniz Bir
sonraki derste görüşmek üzere alfidan
ziyanı yok
[Müzik]